do you think you think like a gangster
at times you have to you there's no
question about it in the business world
sure oh you have to think that way
interesting oh you have to especially uh
in the world of look we're we're friends
we're compelled you know we may talk
here but within your world the bigger
you get there's a lot of people that are
not happy about your brand getting
bigger sure you opening up more gyms
this is not exciting to a lot of other
people that own gyms it's not even
exciting to somebody that runs a
different model when it comes down to
franchising right so you're not helping
people it's helping competitors you're
hurting them sure and when it comes down
to it if it's between your five
locations
versus my five locations they are going
to be competitive so you get in the
world of business being very
everybody wants to help everybody's this
and then you realize there's a part of
it that some of the people would take
their side over you any day all right
now i think the bottom line here as we
start off the show is that uh
entrepreneurship is a lot like being a
gangster it is all right it is minus the
killing and all the other stuff so right
right